- Dans les rues presque
désertes, on n'entend que ça.
Les tirs sont constants.
La ville en porte les traces.
Partout. Mais c'est surtout cet
homme, au sol, victime d'une
explosion alors qu'il roulait à
bicyclette qui donne la mesure
d'où on se trouve : Bakhmout
est un champ de bataille.
"J'ai travaillé dans les mines.
J'ai l'habitude des explosions.
Mais ça, le niveau de décibels
est trop élevé pour qui que
ce soit."
Tatiana ne presse plus le pas,
malgré les explosions.
Elle s'en remet à Dieu.
Tatiana ne presse plus le pas,
malgré les explosions.
Elle s'en remet à Dieu.
"Il faudra beaucoup de temps
avant que ceux qui nous dirigent
règlent ça entre eux. Russe et
Ukrainien, nous allons souffrir
et c'est tout."
Après plusieurs heures,
des policiers viennent enfin
récupérer le corps de celui qui
restera, aujourd'hui du moins,
anonyme.
Vladimir vit juste à côté.
Et regarde la scène d'un mauvais
oeil. Deukrainiens
sont passés plus tôt, sans
chercher à lui porter secours.
"L'armée ukrainienne est venue,
les services d'urgences sont
passés, mais il ne sont pas
allés ve
Il était peut-être en vie."
Vladimir ne cache pas ses
sympathies pour la Russie.
Pourtant, les soldats ukrainiens
sont déployés de son côté, à
l'ouest de la rivière qui sépare
la ville de Bakhmout en deux.
De tels propos feraient pleurer
Galina de rage. Elle vient à la
mairie dans l'espoir de pouvoir
recharger son téléphone, le seul
lien qui lui reste avec le monde
extérieur. Comme tous les
résidents de la ville, elle n'a
plus d'électricité, d'eau ou de
gaz pour faire à manger.
ûr nous avons beaucoup
de traîtres. Vous croyez que
toutes ces explosions, c'est si
simple? Vous savez, si j'étais
plus jeune, je joindrais les
rangs de l'armée. C'est vrai."
Galina est consciente que dans
les villes voisines du Donbass,
Vladimir Poutine a ordonné des
référendums pour l'annexion à la
Russie des territoires que son
pays contrôle entièrement ou en
partie. C'est un idiot dit-elle.
Ailleurs, dans la région de
Kharkiv, l'armée russe bât en
retraite ou tente de freiner
l'avancée des Ukrainiens, ici, à
Bakhmout, les Russes redoublent
d'efforts et mènent une
offensive pour s'emparer du
contrôle de la ville.
Ce serait pour la Russie une
victoire stratégique importante
pour avancer plus au nord. Et un
baume sur la plaie d'une série
de défaites majeures.
Pour l'instant, l'armée
ukrainienne arrive à freiner
l'offensive, mais ses soldats en
paient le prix.
Les habitants eux se demandent
combien de temps tout ça va
durer.
"Il n'y a rien de bon chez
nous. La vie est vraiment
mauvaise. Nous voulons mourir."
Irina voudrait lancer un
puissant cri à la face du monde.
Mais elle n'en a plus la force.
Elle demande qu'on s'imagine
être menacé d'une attaque
nucléaire au Canada.
"Dans d'autres pays, les gens
vivent tranquillement, boivent,
mangent, tombent amoureux,
dorment paisiblement. Nous
n'avons pas ça. Et pour
comprendre cela, il faut le
passer par là."
On ne sait pas combien des
quelque 75 000 habitants de
Bakou sont toujours dans la
ville. Peut-être 10 000, 15 000,
c'est encore beaucoup trop,
selon les autorités.
Ils voudraient bien pouvoir
évacuer tout le monde avec
l'intensification des combats
et l'hiver qui approche.
Il y a bien de la distribution
d'aide pour ceux qui restent,
mais elle est sporadique. À
quelque 5 kilomètres de
Bakhmout, dans le village de
Chasiv Yar, on s'inquiète aussi
de voir autant de gens refuserds
russes de plus en plus
soutenues.
Tous les jours depuis une
semaine, Ruslan Primienko
déplore des victimes.
Partir d'accord, mais ce n'est
pas si simple. Les échanges de
tirs sont souvent trop intenses
pour s'aventurer sur les routes
sinueuses et accidentées. Le
groupe Mozart, composé d'anciens
militaires étrangers
volontaires, est souvent appelé
à la rescousse.
Cette fois-ci, une seule femme
acceptera finalement de partir.
Elle laisse Viktor, son mari
ville. Peut-être 10 000, 15 000,
c'est encore beaucoup trop,
selon les autorités.
Ils voudraient bien pouvoirévacc
l'intensification des combats
et l'hiver qui approche.
Il y a bien de la distribution
d'aide pour ceux qui restent,
mais elle est sporadique. À
quelque 5 kilomètres de
Bakhmout, dans le village de
Chasiv Yar, on s'inquiète aussi
de voir autant de autant de genr
de partir malgré des frappes
russes de plus en plus
soutenues.
Tous les jours depuis une
semaine, Ruslan Primienko
déplore des victimes.
- Chaque citoyen de notre pays
un Ukrainien et on doit sauver
notre peuple.
Hier à Kharkiv il y a encore un
mort.
Partir d'accord, mais ce n'est
pas si simple. Les échanges de
tirs sont souvent trop intenses
pour s'aventurer sur les routes
sinueuses et accidentées. Le
groupe Mozart, composé d'anciens
militaires étrangers
volontaires, est souvent appelé
à la rescousse.
Cette fois-ci, une seule femme
acceptera finalement de partir.
Elle laisse Viktor, son mari
derrièreIl faut bien garder la
Cette fois-ci, une seule femme
acceptera finalement de partir.
Elle laisse Viktor, son mari
derrière. Il faut bien garder la
maison dit-il.
"Nous avons peur bien-sûr, je ne
sais pas qui n'aurait pas peur.
Tout le monde a peur mais nous
allons survivre d'une manière ou
d'une autre."
C'est Lena, un pseudonyme qui
sert de contact au groupe Mozart
ici et coordonne l